so somebody that kind of lives like on
the straight and narrow like this does
it affect you I mean I guess you
wouldn't have anything to compare it to
but when you start getting negative
stories about you because every six
months we're good for a something a
negative DJ Miller story that's like
what the [ __ ] I see what this wetland
girl before you just before everybody I
mean it's on the same line like does it
make you go like you know I'm trying to
but I've been talking about the Internet
in general as like what having turned
the world into high school where gossip
is immediately true like if you were in
school and you found out somebody said
you know so-and-so is a [ __ ] then
everybody started just be like she's a
[ __ ] and no matter what she had done or
there's no there's no court of law
to be able to for her to prove like
anytime you get into the he sheds he
said she said stuff you get into a very
difficult gray area because there's no
proof either way but people love to
bully and mob mentality is very easy to
get into and yeah I mean I think as of
late we've been incredibly unfairly
treated and I may have welcomed some of
it by sort of leaving Silicon Valley and
leaning into the emoji movie and because
I just thought that would be a funny
thing to do but for some reason people
sort of translated that to arrogance or
me being an [ __ ] or stupid and I
think now you know you were about to
bring up Alex yeah but to me he's from
Silicon Valley yeah but to me it's like
you know that's and I don't know she may
have had that experience but it's it's
again people trying to enter the
headlines get in the cycle the media
cycle break the cycle for a second and
then halves but I it was not my
experience that anybody was bullying her
or being was your relationship like what
it means her well I you know truthfully
I felt like it was difficult to work
with her because she kept interrupting
Zach woods you know and and that was my
perspective of it people do you mean alt
like when they were talking no during
takes sir and even when she was
off-camera and so I I don't I don't
think that anybody was bullying her I
think at the very least there was some
sort of disk obviously there was a
disconnect because she's saying these
negative things about me and then
attacking the mostly all-male cow
of Silicon Valley and it's just you know
I guess by force I'm getting better at
better at just saying okay these are
completely untrue things that are being
told about me there are millions of
people that absolutely believe these
things but there are hundreds of
millions of people that don't or don't
care or have tuned all of this out
because so much of the media is like
so-and-so slams you know Jimmy Kimmel
totally drags Kanye West they can't talk
Kathy Griffin face [ __ ] the idea of the
Anderson Cooper it's just all like new
clickbait anger mean-spirited stuff and
so a lot of people have kind of checked
out of it and all the shows that I go to
all I get afterwards in terms of
feedback is like thank you thank you for
coming and performing comedy everything
is so dark right now
yeah these really odd right yeah really
really dark and it's a part of it and
they're just throwing gasoline and coal
into the fire yeah it cold because they
just wanted to keep simmering and keep
burning but already somebody's thrown
more gasoline on it and jokingly said in
a vulture piece a long time ago I was
like you know I'm okay being the villain
but I didn't really understand that then
once the election happened
people were really looking for villains
and there are some real villains out
there and they've been brought to
whatever kind of justice I guess they've
been brought to but then there's some
people that are just being thrown under
the tank treads and there is no recourse
there's no way to come to come back from
it you know what I mean I've always been
curious about like when so when that
kind of headline comes out the tweet
comes out there she says like you were
you you bullied her and and then every
single box alter everything because your
total is eveni where there's just copy
and paste yeah that's exactly at these
days often they grab it and they [ __ ]
on me and pay do you go oh [ __ ] yeah I
guess it was tense on that set I was
worried that this would come back or do
you go what the [ __ ] doesn't come out of
the blue I think it's much more the
latter than the former I mean I
certainly didn't expect I wouldn't have
expected her to say something like that
I you know if anything she left and I
felt like they had well here's an
interesting this is actually fairly I
shouldn't be saying it but I find this
interesting
I thought that they were a little bit
mean-spirited about the way that they
brought her back for like just a quick
scene and then said now if I forget her
like nevermind why I think she expected
more well I you know I think that they
were sort of speaking through the show
too I mean I don't know I can't speak
for them but like the way that they got
rid of the Ehrlich character well I I
walked from the show because I thought
that that was such a perfect ending for
him to just sort of disappear into the
ether I thought it would end the
cyclical nature of the show I thought
that it would give people like jinyang
which it has Jimmy O yang a lot more
room I was hoping that Amanda crew would
get more room which I haven't seen as
much but she's incredibly hilarious and
you know then they made it that jinyang
was trying to prove I was dead by
getting a dead pig and burning the pig
and I thought that was very funny guys
who Ehrlich was a pig it's kind of a pig
of a man on that show and so you know I
mean I why I don't I'm not able to then
go I can't believe how unfairly they
treated me and compared me to a pig they
compared a man to a pig that's
impossible
what about you [ __ ] what sons of
[ __ ] bullying me around comparing me
a pig no I was a pig of a man and I do
not I think it's much more with the [ __ ]
because there's no if you talk to
anybody who's worked with me and these
but these people don't like suddenly
break the news cycle by being like just
work with TJ in office Christmas party
and I thought it was a lovely experience
isn't gonna be like you know use there's
a lot of humility to him and we had a
great time I felt like I could trust him
and we had excellent conversations in
the trailer over swea you know
SmartWater see that's not gonna break
the cycle no wonder he's like this guy's
a piece of [ __ ] and everybody enabled
him being a piece of [ __ ] and I think
you can kind of feel there is a
disconnect with a lot of people that
either know my work or know me you can
kind of feel that I am NOT a bully I
don't think I have the energy of
somebody who comes in and is like hey
shut up okay the men are talking right
now like that's not a Kamiya to be fair
you're acting a little effect but it's
just a confusing time right now where
there's so much anger and so they don't
know where to fire no it's all mistake
though you run the [ __ ] fire on
anybody you run the risk of people being
like okay well TJ's a lot right and so
it's like you either like TJ or it's
like nah no no he's too much but you run
this risk of being like oh I found TJ
annoying so let me transfer that energy
into attacking his character and make
well and let me buy the by just happened
to break the cycle and get my name in
the headlines right in the sudden right
and so there is that but I definitely I
had a reputation in Hollywood as sort of
a benevolent benign maniac you know I am
a maniac I mean I did six sets last
night for no money and didn't eat it all
he got up at 5:00 and I was cooking
pizzas for people that don't even care
to eat but we do enjoy the smell I think
that and then by cultivating a sort of
persona that is true to life the is just
kind of I'm a bit of a maniac I think
then people if they don't know what to
do with you then they quickly are
looking to categorize you figure out
what sort of it you know I mean I always
refer back I know I keep referring but
I've just studied your work so much but
I think people quickly will say well
that's that there's some deviance to
that so that guy's a pervert right right
she's she's strongly defining the fact
that she wants to sleep with who she
wants to sleep with what she's a [ __ ]
mm-hmm you know I mean all of those
things are equally as bad but the you
know Hollywood as well as just culture
in general and society is always looking
to try and place you and right now they
really have pushed me over to the side
of like villain and when these headlines
come out you feel the impact oh yeah and
I think you know Kate feels the impact I
mean can you turn it off though can I
not think of it I mean that's what I've
been trying to do lately but it's tough
I also have to monitor sort of how
people are seeing me and I have to be on
social media to promote shows and stuff
so I can't you necessary I can just quit
going on social media like some of my
friends have but people don't think
about or care that there's me and you
know Kate is at home reading this stuff
and you know I'm gonna point now where
she's like don't really mention me in
social media because you get so much
hatred coming at you and to to hear your
own wife
say that she doesn't want to be
associated with you on you know online
now that was a pretty tough conversation
and I'm very very sad but I think people
just don't they don't care it doesn't
matter to them that there's a wounded
guy or that there's something that said
it's a lie or it's just someone's
perspective it doesn't matter that's
what some papers it's a really getting
what he deserves right right well and
that's what it is is or or an assaulter
or whatever lik whatever the accusation
is it's now you're getting what you
deserve
yeah but it's but but then the other
weird thing about that is like if it's
completely not true okay which it is not
then you get into this strange gray area
of like also why do you want to now
persecute people without any sort of
trial or any what what I don't get that
because you've been persecuted you now
want to become the bully no because it's
just a temporary fix
like there's bobbing the people who are
piling on so that is that is I mean you
know if you're talking about Alice it's
like I understand her perspective but
she was kind of being mean by sort of
attacking me and calling me names and
then calling out all of the people on
Silicon Valley and and just like calling
out the fact that we were all men and
because we were men we were shitty and
we'd created this toxic work environment
all that kind of stuff it's you know so
okay so what happened so now she's being
mean to the people who are mean to her
and so now everyone can get behind that
and then there's some sort of justice
there it doesn't that mean folia yeah
that was that Nannette thing a little
bit is like you've had I've been doing
jokes about this you [ __ ] straight
white male you piece of [ __ ] like you've
been oppressive which most I don't know
I voted for Hillary Clinton I don't need
the maximum amount of money that I could
to her I didn't necessarily like her as
a candidate at all but I thought it was
the lesser of two evils and more than
I thought it would have been a momentous
occasion to have a female president all
that being said it's weird that now it's
like because you made us it's just it's
an eye for an eye
well the people that we're getting their
eyes taken out or screaming for fairness
and equality and justice and don't you
know don't attack me just because I'm
different and because you've been
attacking me because I'm different or
people like you have been then but now I
get to attack you once I get you down
it's like I once said an eye for an eye
leaves everybody blind your name under
that quotes oh yeah yeah yeah there's so
many a text people have taken it this
feels like a little bit of a heavy
conversation to have over deep-dish
pizza in the morning
Wow while we're talking about you being
a maniac can we can you talk I don't
know if you can legally or not go you
can't talk about the impression stuff
cuz it's an ongoing yeah absolutely not
no I mean and you know what it isn't
yeah there's just it it's it's a
misunderstanding that I have with the
federal government and now that's kind
of the end of it to those ends and it's
but it's very difficult because that in
and of itself not speaking on that
subject but just in general that kind of
added to the public's perception of
exactly what you're saying that's why
you brought it up you're like well are
you truly a maniac and it's like no I am
NOT I mean I'm you know I'm a person who
dresses like an [ __ ] on purpose but
I'm not a person that you know I play an
[ __ ] on TV but I am NOT a bully in
real life ever if anything all of my
efforts for the most part are altruistic
I mean I'm traveling the country as a
stand-up comedian I'm making much less
money than I would on Silicon Valley
because I feel like I can reach more
people and I think that live performance
is so much more important now in the
wake of all of this content and all of
the streaming and people just kind of
zapping out in front of the television
and so you just it's it's a very dark
time and Kate and I are getting thrown a
lot of the darkness that is associated
with it or rather just the anger there's
just so much anger yeah